people don't speak as they wait in line
standing one meter apart the queues
growing outside supermarkets there are
no smiles there's a sadness here but no
stockpiling people buying what they need
in silent solidarity for each other
taxi drivers now insist passengers
maintain their distance as they rattled
through Rome's
empty streets invincible invincible yes
we need journey if I don't bits up
hellebore oh come upon zero
in the last few weeks
Stephanie Capelli's incomes dropped to
30 euros a day input quantity Berea
shake ethey you're seeing
amazing we're going on
we're not
or supports it for some today is the
first time they've stepped outside since
lockdown began this family now more
worried for friends and family in the US
and UK you know you started counting
well who might I lose well this
grandmother and that grandfather of my
brother who's immunocompromised you know
when you're counting out the people who
might die it's awful but here in Italy
nearly a week into this lockdown this
resentment some are bending the rules
essential reasons for leaving the house
seem loosely defined and loosely
enforced some European countries worried
there as little as 10 days behind the
crisis levels here in Italy Italians
have now been on lockdown for six days
but few could have predicted scenes like
this an empty sump Peter's Square at the
Vatican City where thousands are usually
gathering ahead of the Pope's weekly
address Easter gatherings have already
been cancelled here two Italians willing
this lockdown is lifted long before then
Sally Lockwood Sky newsroom